today is the second day of hanukkah  fremont street experience kicked out the  holiday season last night with the  lighting of their grand menorah it'll  remain on display throughout the  hanukkah season which lasts eight days  also at the grand menorah lightning last  night the dancing dreidels from the  chabad of southern nevada  and we're actually going to have them on  the show on good day tomorrow morning  they'll be dancing of course but they'll  also be talking more about hanukkah and  the traditions involving that so we  certainly of course hope that you'll  tune in tomorrow morning on good day for  a little dancing dreidel action